So let's review. Last class we discussed
the mission of Jesus.
Who is Jesus? Jesus was a messenger from
the monad
who reminded us that there's a divine
spark in us.
And how you activate the divine spark is
by focusing on Jesus and repeating his
words. Jesus was like Zorusta, like
Plato, like Homer, like the Yahweh, a
poor prophet. And so if you just
repeated his sayings, if you repeat his
poetry, then you could activate that
spark within you and you could glow.
Okay? And this explains why it became so
popular. It also explains to us why the
Romans had to kill him. Because at this
time the Roman empire
the main currency the main economy is
based on slavery. Most people were
slaves. If they're not slaves they were
poor. And here is Jesus who's come to
remind you that you don't have to be a
slave. You are free to do whatever you
want. There's a higher power than the
Roman Empire and it is the divine. It is
the universe. And so people start to
defy their masters and they were no
longer afraid of death. And this is why
the Romans had to kill Jesus because
Jesus was stealing from them. Right?
Slaves are property. If you let slaves
run away, if you free slaves, that
destroys the wealth of the Romans.
Remember that Jesus when he was killed,
he was killed along with two thieves. He
was crucified
and so Jesus was killed because he was a
thief. He was stealing from the Romans.
Now the question then is okay
um how do we Jesus to the Catholic
Church? Jesus teaches us that we are
free to believe whatever we want. That
we just listen to our hearts. We will be
in touch with the monad again and we
have nothing to fear. The Catholic
Church, the church teaches us that you
believe in Jesus and that's all you have
to do in order to achieve redemption and
salvation. Jesus came to die for our
sins. So therefore, we are now slaves to
Jesus. These are two opposite ideas.
Okay. The reason why is the idea of the
divine spark is the greatest threat to
Roman Empire. So the Romans had to
somehow imprison the spark and make it
an economic commodity. Okay? And so
that's why they created the Catholic
Church. The Catholic Church is a prison
in order to control that divine spark to
hide it from you. And the main architect
of the Catholic Church is his name is
Paul. Okay? And most people agree that
Paul and not Jesus is the real founder
of Christianity.
So let's discuss Paul. So Paul has a
very interesting background. He is a
Jew,
but he grew up in Greek culture. He was
very well educated. He was very wealthy.
And this and so we say he's a helanized
helanized Jew
and is probably working for the Roman
Empire as a spy or an agent.
Now
in that time your education was mainly
in rhetoric. Okay. The word we use for
this is sophistry.
So let me explain to you who the
sophists were because they're very
important. So back in classical Athens
there's a major debate between Socrates
a philosopher as well as a sophist
philosophy. So what's interesting is
that they both come from the same word
which is sophia which is Greek for
knowledge.
The philosophers are people who love
knowledge. What they believe is that
there's an eternal truth and that we
must try to achieve this eternal truth.
Right? Remember Plato's allegory of the
cave? How you escape from the cave and
into the light. Okay? That's what
philosophy is trying to do. Trying to
help you uh liberate yourself into the
light. Sophist believe something else.
Sus believe that eternal truth does not
exist. Why? Because words
are reality.
Philosophers believe that words are an
illusion. But sisters believe that words
are a reality unto themselves. And so
what's important is to learn how to
master
language in order to construct reality.
Okay. So um surface gives us the word
surface which is basically trickery.
Okay. So in order to defeat the threat
of the divine spark, what Paul does is
he pulls a trick and it's the greatest
trick ever. The trick is this.
Jesus says, "Listen to my words and you
will find divine spark in you." What
Paul says is, "Believe in Jesus and
you'll be saved." Okay. So he changes
the focus from the words of Jesus to the
person of Jesus himself.
All right? And so what Paul's going to
do is he's going to construct a new new
religion called Christianity
by synchronizing
synthesizing
the three major cultures of that time.
The Roman culture, the Greek culture and
the Jewish culture. Okay. So remember
the Jewish culture is the Bible
and what Paul tells us is that Jesus is
the promised Messiah.
At this time in history uh the Bible is
heavily influ influenced by the
Persians, right? Remember the Persians
were montheists. They believed in good
and evil, the Asher and the Jews. Okay?
And so the Bible began to reflect the
Persian belief especially in the idea of
esquetology
the end of the world. And what Jews
believed is
they're not afraid of the Romans because
eventually the Messiah will return or
sorry not return the Messiah will come
to lead them to war against the Romans
and because the Messiah is anointed by
God they will triumph. Okay. So the Jews
are waiting for the Messiah of war in
order for them to reclaim the dev the
Davidic kingdom. Okay, the kingdom of
David.
What Paul does that's very clever is
that he uses this esquetology, but he
says that Jesus is not the Messiah of
war. He's the Messiah of
peace. Okay?
And therefore, we Jews should not resist
the Romans. Okay. So that's the first
major culture that Paul uses. The second
major culture that Paul uses is the
Greek culture.
So um the Greeks have something called
the mystery schools.
And these are just cults. And it's
important you know these mystery schools
because they will become the basis of
secret societies today.
And in these mystery schools, there's
lots of different ones, but Paul chooses
a mystery school that worships
Dionis.
Okay, Dianis is the Greek god of
creativity, wine. Um, and the story of
Dianius is he is born of a virgin
mother.
His father is Zeus. And then Dianus is
killed by the enemies of Zeus and Zeus
finds him and resurrects him. Okay, it's
important because this becomes the story
of Jesus
and the pe how the how that how the
people uh worship Dianis is they have a
ritual meal where they actually believe
they're eating the body of Dianis and
they're absorbing his energy
and they're becoming one with Dianis.
They're they're coming communion with
dynasties and the Christians have the
same ritual. Okay. And this is what
what's called the eukarist
uh thanksgiving or communion.
Okay. And all Christians practice this
today. Okay. So that's the second major
culture. The third major culture that is
the most important of course is the
Roman culture.
So the Roman social structure
is called the patter
familias.
Okay. And how the system works is at the
very top there's one patriarch.
This where where we get the word
patriarchy, right?
And then
he has lots of children, right? sons and
also has slaves as well.
So it's a very topdown system, right?
The patriarch patriarch's at the very
top. In the system, the patriarch is
always right. He is God. Here you have
slaves. Now what the patriarch will do
is he will identify
very promising slaves, slaves with
talent and will turn them into clients.
So clients are just business people. So
he frees the slaves and they become his
clients. So now they're able to conduct
business on his behalf and in this way
he will create a business empire. Okay.
So this is the idea of
the Roman Empire. So rather than one
system, the Roman Empire is actually a
system, a platform where dozens of
families control the empire together.
And what happens is these families
control a particular province. Okay? So
it's more like a franchise model rather
than than a strict hierarchy.
This is important because Paul will take
the system and from the system he will
copy it to create the church.
All right. So the church is exactly the
same as a paraphras where at the very
top you have a person a bishop
and every and then he might have some um
cardinals
but then everyone else is just followers
okay or disciples.
So it mirrors the system.
This is important because now what you
can do is you can easily switch from the
current system to the new system devised
by Paul.
Now why would the Romans want to do
this? Because if you think about it,
this is the perfect solution to the
problem of Jesus. As a patriarch, your
main concern is getting your slaves to
work hard, right? You want to suck the
energy out of them.
But now with Jesus, slaves are like,
"Why? Why should I work for you?" Paul
solves this problem by saying, "Oh,
follow Jesus and you'll be saved." Okay?
So in this way, what happens is
Paul's formulation of Jesus causes
slaves to work even harder, right?
Because idea is before you have to work
in order to stay alive. Now they work in
order to go to heaven for all of
eternity, right? So the deal now is work
as a slave for a few decades, but then
you can enjoy an eternity of joy and
paradise. Pretty good deal, right? And
so this causes the slaves to be more
obedient and to work harder.
Okay. Also, what's more important is now
the patriarch switches from a king to a
god, right? His private wealth now now
becomes spiritual authority.
Not only that, but because he has
spiritual authority, he can expand more
rapidly outwards. Okay?
So, before to get slaves, you have to
buy slaves. Now you you just have to
convert people into your religion. So
it's a much faster way to create wealth.
And this is important because what you
learn next class is this is a system
that the Romans will use to
um take over the barbarians. Okay. So
next class you'll learn about the
barbarian invasions basically the Goffs
and how because of the system they were
now able to
assimilate these barbarians into the
culture and maintain a social hierarchy.
Okay? And so in other words Jesus was
talking to slaves but Paul was talking
to patriarchs.
And so these patriarchs would convert
and when they convert they took the
entire system with them. That explains
the rapid growth of [snorts]
Christianity.
Okay. Also what's important is the
religion that the patriarchs practice is
not the one that the slaves practice.
The slaves practice Christianity but the
patriarchs
practice the mystery cults. Okay? Why?
because this is the way that the
patriarchs
work together and this becomes a basis
for secret societies.
So while the ordinary person worships a
new religion called Christianity, the
patriarchs themselves in secret still
practice their Greek mystery cults. This
is a system that we still have even
today.
All right. Okay. So um this system now
is able to spread really quickly because
as you can see from the system those who
convert are more advantage than those
who do not convert. At this time in
history most do not convert but those
who convert are able to see more rapid
wealth generation. They're able to see
more power generation and they're able
to expand much faster. And so this is a
secret of Christianity.
Okay? And that's my main argument to you
today.
Any questions before I go into the
specifics? Is this clear to you guys?
All right. Let's do the PowerPoint.
Okay.
Okay. Today we do the rise of the
Catholic Church. Okay. So again, what
Paul's going to do is he's going to
negate the power of Jesus. He's going to
imprison, sorry, he's going to imprison
the divine spark in the church. All
right?
So this is Paul and there's a lot of
mythology around Paul, how he's a martyr
who went around the world in order to
spread Christianity. Okay? We don't know
if it's true or not. If you're Catholic,
you believe it's true. Um the other
thing about Paul that's really important
is that if you read the New Testament,
a third is either written by Paul or
about Paul. Okay, there's more about
Paul and the New Testament than there's
about Jesus. That's why that's why we
say that Paul is a true founder of
Christianity. Christianity is a religion
about Jesus, but not by Jesus. It's by
Paul.
And what's really important for you to
appreciate is what Jesus taught and what
Paul taught are very different. In fact,
they're opposite. Jesus taught that the
divine spark is within you. So if you
want to save yourself, if you want to go
to the kingdom, you must do so yourself.
But Paul says, "No, Jesus came to us in
order to redeem us from our sins, the
original sin um of disobedience to God
way back in the Garden of Eden. If you
believe in Jesus, you'll be saved.
Doesn't matter what you do,
but you you you can do as much good as
you want, but if you do not believe in
Jesus, you will burn in hell." Okay?
That's why you must believe in Jesus.
And that's also why we must get everyone
to believe in Jesus because by getting
everyone to believe in Jesus, we are
literally saving them from eternal
damnation. As you can see, this is a
really good business
uh model because now you can expand
really quickly. Okay. Second thing that
Jesus taught is
he cannot save you. You can only save
yourself. He can guide you. We can give
you some poetry that you can decipher,
but you must seek truth yourself. And
what Paul taught is don't think for
yourself, just do what everyone else
does. He believed the most important
thing is for the church to be cohesive.
Okay? For everyone to obey the word of
Jesus, which is really the word of Paul.
And the third thing is, and this is the
most, this is really important. Jesus
teaches us the rich cannot enter heaven.
Why? Because to enter heaven, you must
focus on your own spiritual
rejuvenation. But the rich only care
about the here and now. They only care
about the material acquisition and as
such they become blind to the spiritual
needs and so they do not they cannot
enter the kingdom of heaven. Remember
Jesus tells the story of how the God has
prepared a great feast for us, but the
rich won't go because they're too busy
making money.
Paul teaches us, "No, no, no guys, it's
the rich which will lead us to the
kingdom." Why? Because the rich can
finance the spreading of Christianity.
What matters is metrics that help us
spread Christianity. How many souls are
we saving by measuring how many how many
people we're converting? Okay, how
cohesive is our church? That's all care
Paul cares about. Paul is a business
person. [clears throat] Okay, Jesus is a
prophet, but Paul is a business person.
And so it is Paul really that
um is the spiritual
god of Christianity, okay? Not Jesus.
Another thing that you need to
appreciate is at this time in history
maybe the year 40 50 there are lots of
different Christianities because Jesus
taught us that the kingdom of heaven is
within you right so it's all very
diverse it's all very democratic and
what's really important is a lot of the
early leaders are woman okay uh people
like Mary Meline um they tend to be
wealthy and they tend to be very um
charismatic as
But by the time you hit Paul
Christianity, it's anti-woman. It's a
strict hierarchy and it's orthodoxy.
Okay? So, in other words, you may you
may have heard that early Christians
were persecuted. Guess what, guys?
They're being persecuted by Paul. Okay?
They're being Christian being persecuted
by the Romans. They're being persecuted
by Paul. And at this time in history,
the Catholic Church, okay, Paul, Paul
and Christianity, it's only a very small
minority for because for most people um
the Christian of Jesus is much more
appealing than the Christianity of Paul.
Jesus taught freedom, empowerment,
liberation. Paul taught obedience,
discipline,
sacrifice. Okay? So Jesus is far more
appealing. But because Paul is being
supported by the Roman Empire, he wins.
Okay. What Paul will do is not only
persecute other Christianities, but he
will quickly spread his Christianity
with the help of the Roman Empire.
All right. So, as you can see, what's
going to happen is in the year 30 when
when Jesus dies, it's a very small group
of people, but it spreads really
quickly. Okay. and um built the
foundations for this great empire that
in about the year 300 reaches its peak.
Okay. In about the year 300, what will
happen is Christianity becomes the
official religion of the Roman Empire.
And this is the beginning of the
Catholic Church. But it's Paul that
built the foundation for this growth.
[snorts]
Okay. Um so as you can see um Jesus he's
spreading his poetry and it's because
his poetry is easy to memorize this his
poetry spreading really quickly
throughout the empire. Okay. But uh what
will happen is that once Paul builds the
structure of Christianity, the church
system based on the pattern pattern
system of the Romans, it will spread
even quicker and eventually these two
Christianities will come into conflict
and eventually Paul's system will win
out until it conquers the entire Roman
Empire. Okay.
All right. So um
scholars agree that Paul is the founder
of Christianity. But there are three
mysteries to Paul that scholars can't
really answer. Okay. The first question
is
why would someone like Paul who is a
literate and wealthy Jew, why would he
join a movement of illiterate Jewish
peasants? Okay. No. No. The scholars
don't really have an answer for this.
Second question is we know that Paul was
a fanatical Pharisee. Okay, he he was
hunting Christians but then he converts
to become a fanatical follow of Jesus.
Why would he do that? Okay. The third
mystery is this the most important is
he spends his entire life promoting
Christianity around the Roman Empire.
Where did he get the money to do this?
Because not only did he go, but he he
also had secretaries who went with him
to take notes. Where's where does the
money come from? Okay, so if you just do
some basic game fair analysis, he's
clearly a spy. Okay, clearly a spy. He's
an agent of of a power. The question for
us though is who is he working for? The
easy answer seems to be the Roman
Empire. But in fact, you could also make
the argument he's working for the Jewish
leaders. Okay, the Jewish priests as
well. Okay, so we we'll go over this.
All right, so what we're going to do is
we're going to read the Bible now. Okay.
Now, one thing about the Bible that um
is very confusing is the Bible says that
the Jews killed Jesus. And as we
discussed last class, the Jews would not
kill Jesus for a variety of reasons.
Okay. Um, but the main reason is Jews
don't kill each other. Well, I'm sorry.
Jews do not turn each other over to the
Roman authorities. If you commit
blasphemy, if you insult their god, they
kill you by stoning you. Okay? They
don't have a habit of turning people
over to the Roman authorities. So, we
know the Romans killed him. And it's
most likely the Romans killed him
because Jesus Jesus was a threat to
their social structure. But the Bible
says that nope, it was the Jews who
killed um
Jesus. So Emmer, could you read please?
>> Okay, so this is from John the Gospel of
John.
>> Then Pott took Jesus.
>> Palad Pontius Pilot is a Roman governor
who who orders Jesus' execution. Okay.
>> Pilot.
>> Yeah. Pontius Pilate.
>> Then Pilate took Jesus and had him
flocked. And the soldiers wo a crown of
thorns and put it on his head. And they
dressed him in a purple robe. They kept
coming up to him saying, "Hail, king of
the Jews." And striking him on the face.
Pilot went out again and said to them,
"Look, I am bringing him out to you to
let you know that I can find no case
against him."
>> Okay, so what's happening is Jesus is
arrested by the Jewish priest and they
accuse him of blasphemy, of pretending
to be God. And they bring him to
Pontious Pilot, the governor, and says,
"You must execute this man because he
has insulted our religion." And so
Pontius Pilate interrogates Jesus and he
doesn't really think he did anything
wrong. Okay? But to to appease the
priest, he beats he whips Jesus. And now
he's like, "You know what? I whipped
this guy. I punish him. Now, could you
please go away?" Okay? Keep on going.
>> Pilate went out again and said to them,
"Look, I am bringing him out to you to
let you know that I can final case
against him." So Jesus came out wearing
the crown of thorns and the purple robe.
Plet said to them, "Here is the man."
When the chief priests and the police
saw him, they shouted, "Crucify him!
Crucify him!" Pilot said to them, "Take
him yourselves and crucify him. I find
no case against him." The Jews answered
him, "We have a law, and according to
the law, he ought to die because he had
claimed to be the son of uh son of God."
>> Okay, so do you understand what's going
on? Okay, the Bible
claims that Jews killed Jesus. All
right. So, um, this teach this shows us
that the Bible is not that reliable. All
right. Okay. So, let's go into the story
of Paul. Um, Allan C, can you please
Okay. So, so, so let let me show give
you the context. Okay. This is from the
acts of the apostles and it's mainly
about Paul and how he became a follower
of Jesus. And at this time, Paul is
persecuting Christians. We don't know
why he's persecuting Christians. We
don't know what why the Jews hate the
Christians, but uh Paul is going around
persecuting the Christians as a
Pharisee. And then on the way to
persecuting more Christians on the road
to Damascus,
he a light seizes him and it's Jesus
telling him, "Paul,
why are you persecuting me and my
followers?" And then that converts Paul.
It makes no sense as a story. Okay, but
this is what Christians believe. Okay,
can can you read Alan? Meanwhile, Saul,
still breathing threats and murder
against the disciples of the Lord, went
to the high priest and asked him for
letters to the synagogue
synagogue synagogues.
>> The the synagogue is a place of worship
for diaspora Jews because Jews worship
the the temple, right?
>> But the temple's in Jerusalem. So if
there if you're outside Jerusalem, then
you go to synagogue, okay? Which
basically a Jewish church
>> synagogues and Damascus. so that if he
found any who belonged to the way, men
or women, he might bring them bound to
Jerusalem. Now, as he was going along
and approaching Damascus, suddenly a
light from heaven flashed around him. He
fell to the ground and heard a voice
saying to him, "So, so why do you
persecute me?" He asked, "Who are you,
Lord?" The reply came, "I am Jesus, whom
you are persecuting. But get up and
enter the city, and you will be told
what you are to do." The men who were
traveling with him stood speechless
because they heard the voice but saw no
one. Saul got up from the ground and
though his eyes were open, he could see
nothing. So they led him by the hand and
brought him into Damascus. For three
days he was without sight and neither
ate nor drink.
>> Okay, so this is a miracle, right? This
guy hated Christians and now because he
was blinded, he loves Christians. What
what you will notice is um this is very
similar to Plato's allegory of the cave
because remember uh Paul's trained in
Greek culture. So he knows about Plato
and this is model of the allegory of the
cave where you're in darkness and
suddenly you go out and you're blinded
by the light and then you see the truth.
Okay. Another thing that's important is
that clearly Jesus favors Paul. What's
interesting is that if you read Paul's
letters, and we all read his letters, if
you read Paul's story, he doesn't really
talk about Jesus that much. He doesn't
even quote Jesus.
Okay? So, that's kind of weird. If you
know, you're a father of Jesus, but you
really don't quote Jesus. And Jesus has
a lot of quotations. He really don't
talk about Jesus that much. And he
doesn't really refer to the story that
much in
um
uh in in his letters. The other thing
that that I will note is that if you
read Jesus, okay, Jesus doesn't really
talk about good and evil, doesn't really
talk about the Bible, um doesn't really
talk himself as a son of God, but Paul
will talk about this a lot. Okay?
All right. So again, Paul's amazing
because he'll go on three different
voyages, miss missionary journeys around
the Roman Empire in order to spread the
gospel of Jesus. This is very, very hard
work. It's also expensive work, okay?
Because you can see how he's going from
different cities, he's going to
synagogues, and he's preaching the
gospel.
Okay?
Um what's what's important to us to
understand is that as Paul is doing this
he's winning a lot of converts because
he's but he's come in contact with James
the just remember James the just is the
brother of Jesus who inherits the
movement. James the just is in Jerusalem
and Paul is going around and spreading
the gospel of Jesus. And so James James
the just hears about this and people are
saying to him Paul's saying Jesus is
God. Is Jesus God? And James does is
like, of course, he's not God. He's my
brother, man.
And so there so there's all this
conflict and eventually what will happen
is it forces Paul to confront James and
just in Jerusalem. According to the
Bible, the main conflict is one of
ideology. Okay? So the Bible says that
James the Jud and Paul both agree that
Jesus is God, the son of God who's come
to our planet to redeem us. But James
the Just believes what's important is to
maintain the faith within the Jewish
tradition. Whereas Paul wants to expand
this tradition outside the Jewish
tradition to encompass the Greeks as
well and the Romans as well. Okay, the G
the Gentiles. And that's where the
conflict arises. And so the main point
of conflict is one of circumcision
because remember Jews circumcise
themselves but the Greeks and Romans do
not circumcise themselves. Uh this is
important because in this time most of
these cities are Greek cities. Greek
cities have a place called gymnasium
where men go to play sports but you play
sports naked. So if you're a Jewish man
they know automatically you're Jewish.
So superstition is a huge point of
division between the Gentiles and the
Jews. And Paul's point is that if you
want to convert, you don't have to
circumcise.
And so the Jews are complaining to James
says, "Hey, Paul is subverting our
tradition. He's saying that Jewish men
uh he's saying that Greek men can come
and and follow religion religion without
being without being circumcised." Okay?
And so there's a lot of conflict between
James the just and Paul. So Paul
actually goes to Jerusalem and he
confronts um uh James the judge and they
and they have they come to an agreement
with each other. Okay. So um but when
Paul goes to Jerusalem people recognize
him and so the Amal wants to kill him.
Okay. Can you read Amber? Up to this
point they listened to him, but then
[clears throat] they shouted, "Away with
such a fellow from the earth, for he
shall not be allowed to live." And while
they were shouting, throwing off their
cloaks, and tossing dust into the air,
the tribune
directed that he was to be brought into
the barracks and ordered him to be
examined by flogging to find out the
reason for this outcry against him. But
when they had tied him up with with
[clears throat] songs,
sorry, Paul said to the centurion who
was standing by, "Is it illegal? Is it
legal for you to fogg a Roman citizen
who is unconddemned?" When the centriion
heard that, he went to the tribune and
said to him, "What are you about to do?
This man is a Roman citizen." The
tribune came to ask Paul, "Tell me, are
you a Roman citizen?" And he said,
"Yes." The tribune answered, "It cost me
a large sum of money to get my
citizenship." Paul said, "But I was born
a citizen." Immediately those who were
about to examine him drew back from him.
And the tribune also was afraid, for he
realized that Paul was Roman citizen and
that he had bound him.
>> Okay, so certain things to notice about
about this writing. First of all, you
can see it's very anti-Jewish. The Jews
just want to kill Paul for no particular
reason. Okay, Paul speaking the truth
and the Jews want to kill him. Okay,
it's a Jewish mob. That's first thing.
Second thing is that it's very
pro-woman, right? It's the Roman soldier
come and save Paul from the mob. And
this story is very similar in fact the
story of Jesus. So Jesus was um arrested
and the mob wants to kill him, right?
And the Romans want to save Jesus but
they can't they cannot stop the mob. But
Paul, it's the same situation with Paul.
But what saves Paul is this. He is a
Roman citizen. Okay? So that's what
saves him. Rome saves Paul. God can't
save Jesus but Rome saves saves Paul.
Okay. So this is propaganda
and this propaganda written of course
for hen Jews like Paul who are waving
between uh loyalty to Rome or loyalty to
uh the Jewish tradition. And what Paul
says is the solution is to become a
Christian because now you can become
become both. You can now become like me
loyal to the Jewish tradition but also
loyal to Rome. Okay.
All right. Alan, can you read please?
>> When we came into Roman, Paul was
allowed
>> Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Um I I I I
need to set this up. Okay. So the Romans
say to Paul, um why do the Jews want to
kill you? And Paul says because they
think think I'm insulting their
religion. And Paul says, I'm a Roman
citizen. So I want an audience with the
emperor. Only emperor can decide my
fate. So the Romans sent him with an
with a soldier escort back to Rome.
Okay. And this is how the acts of the
apostles end. Okay. Can you read um
>> when we came into Rome, Paul was allowed
to live by himself with the soldiers who
was guarding him. Three day later he
called together the local leaders of the
Jews. When they had assembled, he said
to them, "Brothers, though I had done
nothing against our people or the
customs of our ancestors, yet I was
arrested in Jerusalem and handled over
to the Romans." When they had exempt me,
the Romans wanted to release me because
there were no reasons for the death
penalty in my case. But when the Jews
objected, I was compelled to appeal to
the emperor even though I had no charge
to bring against my nation. Okay, this
is really interesting. Okay, this is a
change in the story. Before Paul said
that he wants to return to Rome in order
to face judgment from the emperor. And
what Paul's saying now is
you Jews
attacked me and if I wanted to, I could
complain to the emperor and bring
charges against you Jews. Okay, so he's
showing you the story. He's showing how
powerful he is. Okay, keep on going. For
this reason, therefore, I had asked to
see you and speak with you since it is
for the sake of the hope of Israel that
I am bound with this chain.
>> Okay? So, he's saying, listen, those
guys in Jerusalem harass me and so I've
come back to Rome and I I want to speak
to you Jewish leaders and let's see
let's see if if we can work together
because you piss me off in Rome, I can
unleash the empire on you. Okay? So he's
now threatening these Jewish elders.
Come on, go.
>> They replied, we have received no letter
from Judah from about you and none of
the brothers coming here has reported or
spoken anything evil about you, but we
would like to hear from you what you
think. For with regard to this sect, we
know that everywhere it is spoken
against.
>> Okay. So what they're saying is it's all
misunderstanding, Paul. Okay. We don't
know what's going on. Why don't you tell
us what's going on? Keep on going.
>> After they had set a date to meet with
him, they came to him at his longings in
great numbers.
>> Okay, so basically all the Jewish
leaders have to come because they they
understand that Paul represents the
empire. Okay, keep on going.
>> From morning until evening, he explained
the matter to them testifying to the
kingdom of God and trying to convince
them about Jesus both for from the law
of Moses and from the prophets. So again
what Paul's saying is that Jesus is the
fulfillment of the Bible. He's
fulfillment of prophecy. He is the
Messiah. Keep on going.
>> Some were convinced by what he had just
what he had said while other refuse to
believe.
>> Okay. So now some of these Jewish
leaders are being converted by Paul.
They are now moving towards the
Christian faith. That's how powerful
Paul is. Okay. Keep on going.
>> So they disagree with each other and as
they were leaving Paul made one further
statement. The Holy Spirit was right in
saying to your ancestor through the
prophet Isaiah
>> Isaiah, "Go to this people and say, you
will indeed listen but never understand
and you will indeed look but never
perceive. For this people heart has
grown dor and their ears are hard of
hearing. and they have shut their eyes
and they might not look with their eyes
and listen with their ears and
understand with their heart and turn and
I would hear them. Let it be known to
you then that is salvation of God have
been sent to the Gentiles they will
listen.
>> Okay, so he's saying so he's convincing
some Jewish leaders to convert, right?
But not all convert. And so Paul gets
pissed off and says you Jews are so
stubborn. You don't get it, man. Okay,
but don't worry if you don't get it. The
Gentiles, the Greeks and Romans will get
it. We will win eventually. Okay, keep
on going. And live there two whole years
at his own expense and welcome all who
come came to him proclaiming the kingdom
of God and teaching about the Lord Jesus
Christ with all boldness and without
hires.
>> Okay. So, something I will point out is
this. It looks like
Paul is an agent of Rome. Okay, it looks
like he repres represents the empire.
But why would he write in such a way as
to be so blatant? And so you can also
argue that Paul could be a double agent.
Okay, he pretends to be the an agent, a
spy for Rome, but he's actually working
for the Jewish leadership. Why would why
would the Jewish leader support Paul?
Because by spreading Christianity,
he's spreading the Bible and he and the
Bible says that Jews are God's chosen
people. So he's elevating the status of
Jews in Rome. Okay? So it's not as
simple as it looks. From this, if you
just read it, it seems like Paul is a
spy for Rome. But you think much more
deeply about what he's doing. Why would
he be so blatant and tell people, "Ha, I
represent the empire." Well, maybe
because he's being a real Maybe because
he's he's being a double agent, right?
The thing that you have to remember
about spies is they have no loyalties.
They are double agents are triple
agents. Okay? They're always switching
loy loyalties back and forth. [snorts]
Okay. So now what what I want to do is I
want to go into the actual thinking and
writing of Paul. This is Romans which is
one of his major letters. And in these
letters, what he's going to do is he's
going to articulate to you this new
philosophy of Christianity. Okay? These
these letters become the basis for the
Catholic Church. Okay? So, can you read
Amber, please?
>> Circumcision indeed is a value is a
value if you obey the law.
But if you break the law, your
circumcision has become uncircumcision.
So if those who are uncircumcised keep
the requirements of the law, will not
their uncircumcision be regarded as
circumcision?
>> Okay, so stop. So this is Paul and what
you can see is he's a master of
rhetoric. Okay, the Jews are very clear.
If you are Jewish, you must be
circumcised because circumcision is a is
the sign of a covenant between our
people and God. If you're not
circumcised, you're not Jewish. And what
Paul says, no, what matters is your
heart. What matters is your spirit. If
you have faith in God, that's what
matters. Okay, keep on going.
>> Then those who are physically
uncircumcised but keep the law will
condemn you that that have the written
code and circumcision but break the law.
For a [clears throat] person is not a
Jew who is one outwardly, nor is true
circumcision is something external and
physical. Rather a person is a Jew who
is one inwardly and real circumcision is
a matter of the heart. It is spiritual
and not literal. Such a person receives
praise not from others but from God.
Then what advantage has Jews?
>> Okay. So do you guys understand this is
rhetoric right? This is sophistry where
he's changing the definition of the word
where changing the idea of the word.
Circumcision
is a covenant between the Jews and God.
What Paul says, what matters is not the
physical act. What matters is the faith
in God. Okay? That's a covenant. All
right? [snorts]
And as such, you do not have to be uh
um circumcised. Okay? Uh c can you read,
Alan?
>> But now, apart from law, the
righteousness of God had been disclosed
and is attested by the law and the
prophets. the righteousness of God
through faith in Jesus Christ for all
who believe. For there is no
distinction. Since all have sins and
fall short of the glory of God, they are
now justified by his grace as a gift.
Though the redemption that is in Christ
Jesus whom God put for forward as a
sacrifice of atonement by his blood
effective through faith. He did this to
show his righteousness because in his
divine forbear forbearance he had passed
over the sins previously committed. It
was to prove at the present time that he
himself is righteous and that that he
justifies the one who has faith in
Jesus.
>> Okay. So, Jews believe what's important
is to follow the laws, okay? To be
circumcised, to um rest on the Sabbath,
to only marry within the tribe. And what
Paul says is what's important is your
belief in Jesus, your belief that Jesus
came in order to redeem us from our
sins, the original sin. Okay? That's
what matters now. Before it was these
laws. Before it was these actions. And
now what matters is what you truly
believe. Okay? It is only believe in
Jesus that can save you. You can do as
many good works as you want. You can
follow as many laws as you want. Does
not matter. The key is faith in Jesus.
Okay.
All right.
Okay. Can can you read?
>> Yes. [clears throat] And so, brothers
and sisters, I could not speak to you as
spiritual people, but rather as people
of the flesh, as infants in Christ. I
fed you with milk, not solid food, for
you were not ready for solid food. Even
now, you are still not ready, for you
are still of the flesh. For as long as
there is jealousy and quarreling among
you, you are you not of the flesh and
behaving in courtly according to human
inclinations. For when one says I belong
to Paul and another I belong to Apollos,
are you not merely human?
>> Okay. So what Paul is doing is he's
going around and corrupting the
teachings of Jesus. And other people are
calling calling around and says Paul
this is not what Jesus taught. Okay? And
so what Paul's saying is guys guys we
shouldn't argue. Okay? Because who's
right? Jesus is right. Okay? It's not
what you say. It's not what I say. It's
what Jesus says. So this again is
sustry. It's rhetoric. He's positioning
himself above the debate rather than
engaging debate directly and saying like
what did I Jesus actually teach and what
are the true teachings? Paul's saying
what's important is to obey Jesus. Okay.
What's important is obedience not
debate. Keep on going.
>> What then is Apollos? What is Paul?
Servants through whom you came to
believe as the Lord assigned to each. I
planted Apollos watered but God gave the
growth. So neither the one who plants
nor the one who waters is anything, but
only God who gives the growth. The one
who plants and the one who waters have a
common purpose. And each will receive
wage according to the labor of each. For
we are God's servants working together.
You are God's field, God's building.
>> Okay? So Paul is evil. Okay? Everyone's
saying to Paul, "Paul, you're corrupting
the teachings of Jesus." is and Paul's
saying no what matters is we spread the
message of Jesus and everyone's saying
but what's the message of Jesus Paul
SAYING IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT MATTERS IS
THE GROWTH of Jesus okay this is sustry
keep on going
>> according to the grace of God given to
me like a skilled master builder I laid
a foundation and someone else is
building on it each builder must choose
with care how to build on it for no one
can lay any foundation other than the
one that has been laid that foundation
is Jesus
Now if anyone builds on the foundation
with gold, silver, precious stones,
wood, [snorts] hay, straw, the work of
each builder will become visible. For
the day will disclose it because it will
be revealed with fire and the fire will
test what sort of work it has done. If
what has been built onto the foundation
survives, the builder will receive a
reward. If the work is burned up, the
builder will suffer uh suffer loss. The
builder would be saved, but only as
through fire.
>> Okay, so what Paul's saying is this.
We're all going to work together to
spread the message of Jesus. You may
believe Jesus says one thing, I believe
another thing, but let's not argue,
okay? Let's just keep on spreading the
word of Jesus and we'll see which person
has the biggest church and we'll know
who's right. Okay? So, he's using the
metric of business success, of wealth,
of material acquisition to justify his
faith in Jesus. Okay? And this is the
opposite of what Jesus taught. And
people are saying, Paul, this is not
what Jesus taught us. Paul's like, "No,
no, no. We're going to see who wins out
in the end." Okay, keep on going.
>> Do not know that you are God's temple
and that God's spirit dwells in you. If
anyone destroys God's temple, God will
destroy that person. For God's temple is
holy and you are the temple. Do not
deceive yourself. If you think that you
are wise in this age, you should become
fools so that you may become wise. For
the wisdom of this world is foolishness
with God. For it is written, he catches
the wise in their craftiness. And again,
the Lord knows the thoughts of the wise
that they are feudal. So let no one
boast about human leaders. For all
things are yours, whether Paul or
Apollos or Cphas or the world of life or
death or the present or the future, all
belong to you and you belong to Christ
and Christ belongs to God.
>> Okay? So he's very clever, right? He's
saying yes. Jesus taught us that God's
spirit dwells in you. What this means
isn't that you have free will. What it
means is you don't have free will
because you must do the work of God
which is to spread the message of God
which is to extend the power of God in
this world. Okay. So you see how this is
sustry right? He's tricking people. He's
deceiving people. Jesus taught you the
light is within you and therefore you
are you know God. You just trust
yourself and that's good. And then what
Paul says, no, you are a tool of God.
Okay. Uh, keep on going.
>> Think of us in this way as servants of
Christ and stewards of God's mysteries.
Moreover, it is required of stewards
that they be found trustworthy. But with
me, it is a very small thing that I
should be judged by you or by any human
court. I do not even judge myself.
>> Okay. Okay. All right. So, let's keep on
going. Uh, Alan, can you read, please?
>> [gasps and sighs]
>> When you're a slave when caught, do not
be concerned about it. Even if you can
gain your freedom, make use of your
present condition now more than ever.
For whoever was caught in the Lord as a
slave is a freed person belonging to the
Lord. Just as whoever was freed when
caught as a slave of Christ, you were
bought with a price. Do not become slave
of human masters. In whatever condition
you were called, brothers and sisters,
there remain with God.
>> Okay, so Paul's being very clever again,
okay? Because this message is appealing
to slaves. Jesus taught these slaves,
you're free. And these slaves say to
Paul, "We're free, right?" And Paul
says, "You are free, but you are a slave
to God." Do you understand? Okay.
Therefore, no human can be a master of
you because you're all slaves to God.
He's confusing people. Okay. Uh can you
keep on reading? For though I am free
with respect to all, I have made myself
a slave to all so that I might wing more
of them. To the Jews, I become as a Jew
in order to wing Jews. To those under
the law, I become as one under the law.
Uh under the law, though I myself am not
under the law, so that I might win those
under the law. To those outside the law,
I became at one outside the law. Though
I am not free from God's law, but I'm
under Christ's law, so that I might wing
those outside the law. To the weak, I
become weak, so that I might wing the
weak. I'm become all things to all
people, that I might by all means save
some. I do it all for the sake of the
gospel, so that I may share in its
blessing. Do not know that in a race the
runners all compete, but only one
receives the prize. run in such a way
that you may wing it. Athletes exercise
self-control in all things. They do not
they do it to receive a parish
perishable wealth, but we and we and
imperishable one. So I do not run
aimlessly, nor do I box as though
beating the air, but I punish my body
and enslave it, so that after
proclaiming to others, I myself should
not be disqualified.
>> Okay. So, it's almost like a pep rally,
right? He's a business person. He's
telling his workers, "Go out and sell
those damn hamburgers, man. I don't care
what you do. I don't care how many lies
you tell. Go sell those hamburgers.
Pretend they're healthy. Okay? Pretend
you love hamburgers. Just pretend. What
matters is you go sell those hamburgers.
And guess what, man? Whoever sells those
hamburgers gets a car." Okay? But this
is better than car because this is the
the reward is heaven, eternal paradise,
guys. SO GO AND SELL THOSE HAMBURGERS.
All right.
All right. Um can can you read can you
read the highlighted part, Amber?
>> Uh now in the following instructions, I
do not commend you because when you come
together, it is not for the better but
for the worse. For to begin with, when
you come together as a church, I hear
that there are divisions among you, and
to some extent, I believe it. Indeed,
there have to be faction among you, for
only so will it become clear who among
you are genuine. When you when you come
together, it is not really to eat the
Lord's supper. For when the time comes
comes to eat, each of you goes ahead
with your your own supper, and one goes
hungry and another become drunk. What do
you not have a homes to eat and drink
in? Or do you show contempt for the
church of God and humiliate those who
have nothing? What should I say to you?
Should I commend you in this matter? I
do not commend you.
>> Okay. So, what he's saying is this. When
you come to when you come to a church,
it's very important that you obey the
ritual. Okay? The ritual is communion,
the Eucharist. And you we must remember
this is a ritual where you must follow
the exact protocols. If you do not then
there's no point in coming to church. So
the church is not a place to discuss
Jesus, not to debate Jesus, but to
worship Jesus. Okay, keep on going.
>> For I receive received from the Lord
what I also handed on to you. And the
Lord Jesus on the night when he was
betrayed took a loaf of bread and when
he had given thanks, he broke it and
said, "This is my body that is for for
you. Do this in remembrance of me." In
the same way, he took the cup also after
supper, saying, "This cup is the new
covenant in my blood. Do this as often
as you drink it in remembrance of me.
For as often as you eat this bread and
drink this cup, you proclaim the Lord's
death until he comes. Whoever therefore
eats the bread of drink uh uh eat the
bread or drink the cup of the Lord in an
unworthy manner will be answerable for
the body and blood of the Lord. Examine
yourselves and only then eat the bread
and drink from of the cup. For all who
eat and drink with discerning uh without
discerning the body eat and drink
judgment against themselves. For this
reason, may a few are weak and ill, and
some have died. But if we judge
ourselves, we would not be judged. But
when we are judged by the Lord, we are
disciplined so that we may not be
condemned along with the world. So then,
my brother and sisters, when you come
together to eat, wait for one another.
If you are hungry, eat at home so that
when you come together, it will not be
for your condemnation. about uh about
the other things I will give instruction
when when I come.
>> Okay. So this is a really important
ritual. It's the most important ritual
in Christianity called the Eucharist
thanksgiving. Okay. And in this it's
basically they eat some bread and they
drink some wine and they believe it is
the flesh and blood of Jesus. So Jesus
is entering them. Okay. And as you can
imagine what they're doing really is
negating divine spark in you. Divine
spark is free. It's individual. It's
independent. When you part partake in
the body of Jesus, you become one with
everyone else. Okay? That negates your
individuality that it negates a spark
within you and you become just the
church itself. Okay? And that's the idea
of the Eucharist to destroy your
individuality. All right? And so when
Christians do this, they literally
believe the bread they're eating is the
body of Christ, of Jesus. So Jesus is
entering into you and taking you over.
Okay? Okay. It's possession by Jesus.
Uh yes.
>> Can we see this as a way that they abuse
or exploit Jesus because they are just
eating their body although the body of
Jesus is hollow?
>> Uh no. No. The idea here is that Jesus
is your master. Okay. And when you
partake in Jesus, you become a part of
Jesus
and therefore you must obey exactly what
he wants. Okay? All right. So this is
confusing because it's cannibalism.
Okay. But um as I told you before, this
is actually a very common thing among
the Greek mystery cults where they come
together and they believe that when they
eat food, they're actually eating the
body of Dianesis and Dionis his energy
is is being consumed into you. Okay.
What's important for us to appreciate is
like these mystery cults are demonic.
Okay. So, what else they do is they will
have ritual sacrifices where they will
tear people apart and consume the flesh.
Okay. So, this is from a painting from
the Ubides play describing one of these
mystery codes. Um, okay. So, they will
actually tear a person's body apart to
replicate the death of Dianis and they
consume the body part.
All right. And guess what guys, the
secret society still do the slay. Okay.
So but but what's important to
understand is this actually has a long
tradition. So if you go back to 15,000
years to Europe in the m Magdalinian age
um cannibalism was actually very common.
It was common for religious purposes. So
maybe there was someone that you loved
and he died. What you would do is you
consume his body when he died in order
to remember him forever. Okay? so that
you would have an eternal communion with
him because his soul would go into the
spirit world. But if you had his body,
right, he would always communicate with
you. And that's the idea of
commemorating Jesus like in such a way
when you consume Jesus, Jesus is always
with you. He is now taking possession
over your body. You are now just a body
for Jesus. Okay? Does that make sense?
You've lost your individuality. You've
lost your freedom. You are now
completely possessed by Jesus. when you
um are when you engage in the Eucharist.
Okay. Yes.
>> So the so during that time nobody founds
that like this is disobeying the the
original the original belief of Jesus
like Paul is just using of peoples to
obey.
>> Yeah, that's a really good question.
Okay, most people at this time think
Paul is just evil. Okay, it's like this
is not what Jesus taught us. Jesus
taught us to believe in ourselves. Jesus
would never teach us this demonic thing
of sacrifice. Okay? Jesus came to teach
us that animal sacrifice, human
sacrifice, it's all evil.
Okay? He got rid of that. [snorts] But
again, so at this time in history,
Paul's church, Paul's followers are only
limited amount. Okay? Very few people.
But he doesn't care because he's
building the found the blueprint for an
empire. Does that make sense? Okay. So
when the Romans force this religion on
everyone now everyone has to obey this
you understand if you actually from
first principles try to convince people
the Catholic church is right you can't
really convince that many people but
guess what guys doesn't matter because
most most people are born into the
Catholic church so they are born
believing this stuff okay so so they
can't really think for themselves
[snorts] all right but also remember
cannibalism is very common throughout
history so these are the Aztecs who will
engage in cannonism in order to uh
prepare for war in order to sacrifice um
others for for for the gods.
Okay. Uh again, this is the Magnolian
culture and we found
um lots of places where they engage in
cannibalism during funerals. Okay? And
as you can see, it's very common. It's
very common throughout the world at this
time. And it makes sense if you think
about it, right? If this person is
someone you love and he was very special
to you and you want him to still help
you in life to guide you in life and you
consume his body, a part of his body,
then he'll stay with you forever. Okay?
And this is a way to build group
cohesion in this time. Remember this is
the ice age. So it's very hard to
survive
[snorts]
and um but of course not everyone
practices this as well. Okay. Uh the red
are those who practice cannibalism
during funerals. The blue are just those
who just bury the body and and don't
practice cannibalism.
Um
so what you're not taught is among the
elite this sort of stuff goes on a lot.
So this is 19th century in Victorian
Britain and this is you know the the
British Empire. And guess what guys?
What they like to do is they like to uh
steal mummies from Egypt and eat these
mummies because they believe that these
mummies had some magic qualities. Okay,
so this goes back to the 19th century.
And you think to yourself, oh, you know
what? In the 12th century, we are so
much more advanced. We don't do this
crap anymore. Right? Unfortunately,
this is Albert Einstein's brain. Albert
Einstein before he died said, "Please,
please, whatever you do, do not dissect
my brain." Okay, I know I know you think
I'm I'm the greatest genius in the world
and you want to know how my brain works,
but I'm telling you right now, my brain
is so different from your brain. Please,
whatever you do, do not dissect my
brain. So, of course, a doctor steals
his brain and cuts it into different
pieces. Okay?
Now, let me ask you this question. Let's
just say this doctor were to take his
brain and makes a medicine out of it.
Okay? He takes his brain, cuts up into
like 100 different parts.
And then he takes this medicine and he
sells it to rich people for a million
dollars. Could he find 100 rich people
who would pay a million dollars to eat
ice brain? Yes. Okay. So, as I'm telling
you, the rich are insane.
All right. My my wife tells me that when
I die, it's possible they might want to
dissect my brain as well. So, um please
don't do so, okay? Because my brain's no
different from anyone else's brain.
Okay. You won't find the secret of my
creativity with my brain. All right.
All right. So, um, Yep. Alan, can you
read, please?
>> Yeah.
Indeed, the body does not consist of one
member, but of many. If the foot would
say because I am not a band, I do not
belong to the body, that would not make
it any less a part of the body. And if
the air would say because I'm not an
eye, I do not belong to the body, that
would not make it any less a part of the
body. If the whole body were an eye,
where would the hearing be? If the whole
body were hearing, where would the sense
of smell be? But as it it is God
arranging the member of the body, each
one of them as he choose, if all were a
single members, where would the body be?
As it is, there are many members yet one
body. The eye cannot say to the hand, I
have no need of you. Nor against the hat
to the fa feet, I have no need of you.
On the contrary, the members of the body
that seems to be weaker are
indispensable. And those members of the
body that we think less
uh let me see honorable we close with
greater order. And our less respectable
members are treated with greater
respects. Whereas our more respectable
members do not need this. But God has so
arranged the body giving the greater
honor to the inferior member that there
that the there may be no
>> dension
>> dissension within the body. But the
members may have the same care for one
another. If one member suffers, all
suffers together with it. If one member
is honored, all rejoice together with
it.
>> Okay? So what he's saying is this. Okay?
When you consume the body of Christ,
you've all consume a part of him, right?
And so we we need to come together as a
people, as a church to form the whole
body of Jesus. And that means that you
must do what others tell you to do.
Okay? This requires complete obedience
if we are to resurrect Jesus in our
church. Does that make sense guys? Okay,
keep on going.
>> Now you are the body of Christ and
individually member of it and God has
appointed in the church first a postlets
second prophets. Third teachers, then
deeds of power, then gifts of healing,
form of assistance, form of leadership,
various kind of tongues. Are all all are
allost
apostles? Are all prophets? Are all
teachers? Do all work miracles? Do all
possess gifts of healing? Do all speak
in tongues? Do all inter interpret? But
strive for the greater gift as I will
show you a still more excellent way.
>> Okay. So, do you understand what's going
on? Okay. No matter who you are, no what
you do, what's important is your
sacrifice to Jesus to obey him
completely. Okay. So, this is all
ordained by Jesus. All right. Uh Emer,
can you read the yellow, please?
>> Love is patient. Love is kind. Love is
not envious or boastful or arrogant or
rude. It does not insist of on its own
way. It is not
>> irritable,
>> irritable and resentful. It does not
rejoice in wrongdoing, but rejoice in
the truth. It bears all things, believes
all things, hopes all things, endearest
all things. Love never ends. But as for
prophecies, they will come to an end. As
for tongues, they will cease. As for
knowledge, it will come to an end. For
we all know only [snorts] in part, and
we prophecy only in part. But when the
complete comes, the partial will come to
an end. When I was a child, I spoke like
a child. I thought like a child. I
reasoned like a child. When I became an
adult, I put an end to childish ways.
For now, we see in a mirror dimly, but
then we will cease face to face. Now I
know only in part. Then I will know
fully even as I have been fully known.
And now faith, hope, and love abide,
these three. And the greatest of these
is love.
>> Okay. So you understand Paul does susty.
So you think the word is love. Great
love. We love Jesus. The word actually
means obedience, right?
If you join the church, what is required
for you is complete obedience to Jesus.
Do you understand that you and I are
slave to Jesus? Remember
when we commit the original sin, when we
did evil, we became slaves to the devil.
When Jesus killed us, it's because he
sorry when Jesus died, it was to ransom
us from the devil. So now we are slaves
to Jesus and therefore we must obey him
completely.
Okay? No argument, no opinion, no
individual individuality, just complete
obedience to Jesus. So you can see the
power of this, right? He he switches
these words. He's saying that slavery is
now love.
Okay? When a human master enslaves you,
that's evil. But when Jesus enslaves
you, it's good because now it's love.
It's because Jesus loves you. That's why
he enslaves you. But now, because he
loves you, you must obey him completely.
And that means never ever question the
authority of the church. Never ever do
that because that's evil. Okay.
All right. Uh can you read Alan?
What I'm saying, brothers and sisters,
is this. Flesh and blood blood cannot
inherit the kingdom of God. Nor does a
perishable inherit the imperishable.
Listen, I will tell you a mystery. We
will not all die, but we will all be
changed in the moment, in the twinkling
of an eye, at the last trump trumper
trumpet. For the trumpeter went sound,
and the dead will be raised
imperishable, and we will be changed.
For this perishable body must put on
imperishably,
and this mortal body must put on immort
immortality. When this perishable body
puts on imperishable
uh imperish ability and this mortal body
mortal body puts an immortal immortality
then the saying that is written will be
fulfilled. Death has been swallowed up
in victory. Where oh death is your
victory where O death is your sting. The
sting of death is sin and the power of
sin is the law. But thanks be to God who
gives us the victory through our Lord
Jesus Christ. Therefore, my beloved, be
steadfast, inmovable, always exceeding
in the works of the Lord because you
know that in the Lord your labor is not
too vain.
>> So this is why you must obey him
completely because now you are
guaranteed access to heaven, eternal
paradise. Okay, pretty good deal, right?
be a slave for 40 years, 50 years. Be
the be the best hardworking slave for
the for the next 40 50 years and then
you have eternal paradise because that
is Jesus promise to you. Okay. The the
defeat of death.
>> I think according to the original belief
of Jesus which Jesus led us to pursue
our uh divine spark, right? That's the
real way to heaven. But but doing this I
think like after people die they will
find out that they cannot really go to
heaven because they are slaves.
>> Yeah. No one cares.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. It doesn't matter because you're
dead. Right. Because the entire point of
the system is to extract as much energy
out of you as possible while you're
alive. Right. Because Paul's real
[clears throat] um customers are the
patriarchs. It's the patriarchs who are
paying for this and the patriarchs who
will force their slaves to convert to
this religion. Okay? So maybe the slaves
don't um buy this but their children
will because their children will be
brainwashed into this. Okay? And this
explains why the Catholic Church is the
most powerful organization today.
All right. So um now that we've gone
into how he actually thinks, let's go
over to his psychology. Okay. So what
motivated Paul to do what he did?
Because he worked really hard. And so
there are three possible explanations.
The first explanation is he was a Roman
agent and his mission was to destroy me
Judaism from within. What we'll learn
next class is that Judaism is a huge
problem for the Romans. And so um while
the Jews are praying for me of war, Paul
says, "No, no, no. Jesus was a messiah
of peace." Okay? So he's trying to
subvert the Jews from within. But you
could also argue that Paul was actually
a Jewish spy who sub who's trying to
subvert the Roman Empire by spreading
the Jewish faith. Okay, you could also
argue that. I would argue it's both.
Both are true, right? The real So I
think that what really happened is Paul
had a calling to create his own
religious empire. Okay? He wanted to
become God himself. So there's a famous
joke. The joke goes like this. God and
Satan are having an argument. God says,
"My people, the humans, have found
religion. Therefore, you've lost." And
Satan says, "Well, I'll just organize
it, okay? I'll create churches out of
it." And that's what Paul did. Jesus
came to tell us the truth. And Paul
says, "I'll use this truth and I'll make
an empire out of it." Okay?
All right. So, there's an analogy here.
This is his name is Ray Croc, and he
created the Mc Empire McDonald's. Okay.
How did he do? So he took an idea
McDonald's and he went around America
and he created McDonald's. Okay, so
McDonald's is like it's like the church.
If you go to McDonald's anywhere in the
world, it's the same it's almost the
same building, same menu. Okay, so it so
it follows a very similar pattern to
Paul's building of the church.
Paul was able to succeed because he
because he spread a religion. Ray Croc
succeeded because he also spread a
religion as well. All right. So what he
did was not convince people to buy h to
to eat hamburgers. He didn't need to do
that. What he needed what he needed to
do was convince small business owners to
invest McDonald's to buy the franchise
of McDonald's by spreading the idea of
of the gospel of wealth. If you invest
in me, if you build, if you open
McDonald's, you'll become wealthy and
that is paradise. Okay. So, basically,
Ray Croc and Paul were doing the same
thing.
All right. So, Paul has this business
idea. Let's just take Jesus and turn him
empire. And so, he's going to make
different sales pitches to different
people. Okay? So, we're going to
imagine, okay, and this is just a
thought experiment. It didn't really
happen. We're going to imagine Paul
making a pitch to the Roman patriarchs,
right? He's saying, "Why should you
invest in me?" Because one, we will
cause debate and division within the
Jewish diaspora. Okay? So, some will
convert, but some will not. But who
cares? Because now they're fighting each
other, not fighting us. Okay? That's
number one. Number two is
we will make their messiah of war into a
messiah of peace. Okay? And that will
weaken their resolve. And the third is
we can now spiritually enslave the the
people. Okay? and they'll work harder
for us. So that's a sales pitch of Paul
to the Romans. But there's also a sales
pitch he can make to the Jewish leaders
as well.
Let us spread our faith to the Gentiles
and eleate our status as a chosen
people. Okay? Let us make our Torah in
Jerusalem divine in the eyes of the
world. And guess what? It worked. Right?
Even today, everyone thinks that
Jerusalem is the holy city in the world.
Let us make ourselves a service of the
empire and ally with a Roman patriarchy
so that we can subvert them from within.
All right. And it worked. Now, not all
Jews did this, but a lot did follow uh
Paul into Christianity. Christianity is
a platform for the Jews and the Romans
work together. [snorts]
All right. But now what's what Paul is
going to make a sales pitch to the
Greeks and the Jews. Okay. And this is
what he says. A few decades of obedience
for turning to join paradise. Right?
That's number one. Number two is it's
you to join. You don't you don't have to
get circumcised. Okay. And and the third
is Jesus will return any day now. So
hurry up before it's too late, guys. 50%
off today. All right. DO IT NOW. 50%
OFF. All right. That was that's
literally his message. All right. And
that's why he's so successful. 50% off.
All right. So, what this is Augustine,
okay? And this is after the Catholic
Church becomes the official religion of
the Roman Empire. And what um Austin
will do is he will write a book called
city of God and he will put the Catholic
church above Rome. Okay? Because Rome is
just a temporal earthly city but
Jerusalem is divine city. He's saying
that the Catholic Church is now
Jerusalem. We don't need the Roman
Empire anymore because now we have the
Catholic Church. Okay? The Catholic
Church is a community of believers. As
long as you believe in Jesus, you'll be
saved. So obviously it's going to take
Paul's ideas and systemize it to create
the Catholic Church. Okay? So Emma, can
you read please?
>> It was in secret that the first human
beings began to be evil and the result
was that they slipped into open
disobedience.
>> Okay, so this is really important. Jesus
said there's divine spark in us, right?
Sense, yes, there's divine spark, but
it's from Satan, guys. It's not from
God. It's from Satan. That's why we
cannot trust the divine spark because
we're evil. Keep on going. for they
would not have arrived at the evil act
if an evil would have not preceded it.
Now could anything but pride have been
the start of the evil will for pride is
the start of every kind of sin.
>> So you know Jesus says to
to follow your own heart right and oxy
says no no no that leads to pride and
pride is evil. Pride means you want to
be better than God. Pride means you want
to kill God. Therefore it is inherently
evil. Therefore, the heart inside you
comes from Satan. Okay, keep on going.
>> And what is pride except a longing for a
preserved kind of exultation?
>> For it is a preserved kind of exaltation
to abandon the basis on which the mind
should be firmly fixed and to become as
it were based on oneself and so remain.
This happens when a man is too pleased
with himself and a man is
self-complacent when he deserts that
changeless good in which rather than in
himself he ought to have found it his
satisfaction. This desertion is
voluntary. For if the will had remained
unshaken in its love of the higher
changes good which shed on it light to
see and kindled in its fire to love, it
would not have been diverted from this
love to follow its own pleasure. and the
will would not have been so darkened and
chilled in consequence as to let the
woman believe that the serpent had
spoken to the truth and a man to put his
wife's will above God's commandment and
to suppose that his was a v
>> venial
>> venial transgression when he refused to
desert his life's companion uh companion
even though the refusal entailed
companionship is insin
we exist to obey God. All right. Jesus
taught us that we exist in order to be
creative, in order to seek truth for
ourselves. But obviously Paul teaches us
that we exist in order to obey God. Why?
Because we cannot trust ourselves. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> I have a question. So does that mean um
the believers of the Catholic Church
should not take pride in their identity
as a part of the uh like a part of the
church or does that also mean that they
cannot be will in a way they can't find
satisfaction in
partaking in the great mission of the
Catholic church.
>> Okay. So the Catholic church uh has
certain teachings. Okay. The first
teaching is the idea of original sin
which is we are born evil and it's
Christ that redeems us. That's number
one. Number two is we cannot think for
ourselves because we will be led astray
by the devil. We must listen to the
priest. We should not read the Bible for
ourselves because we'll get confused by
it. Okay. All right. Then and and that's
what leads to reformation.
>> Okay. So
>> and the the and the priests are the
represent representative of God on
earth. The pope has supreme authority.
>> Oh,
>> okay. Yes.
>> So if the pope tells you to take pride
in being a part of the church, you can't
be like you are allowed
>> the pope is the word of God. What
whatever the pope says is the word of
God. Okay.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Okay. It's that simple.
>> So uh I have a question.
>> Go ahead. Yeah. Go ahead. uh like if we
if we really like try to pursue the
original Jesus to believe that is to
pursue our uh divine spark but pride is
a thing that we cannot avoid right
>> yes you will make mistakes right yeah
>> so Jesus says it's okay it's okay to
make mistakes it's okay to screw up
you'll be forgiven whereas Catholic
church says it's not okay to screw up
>> oh
>> yeah do you understand all right
>> okay can you read can you
Thus the evil act, the transgression of
eating the forbidden fruit was committed
only when those who did it were already
evil. That bad fruit could only have
come from a bad tree.
>> Okay, so we're born evil. Okay, it's
that simple. Keep on going.
>> Further, the badness of the tree came
about contrary to nature because without
the fault in the will which is against
nature, it certainly could not have
happened. But only a nature created out
of nothing could have been distorted by
a thought. Consequently, although the
well drives its existence as nature from
its creation by God, it's failing away
from its true being is due to its
creation out of nothing.
>> Okay? So why are we evil? Why can't we
trust ourselves? Why can we be easily
swayed by s by Satan? The reason why is
the Bible tells us that we are created
out of dust. We're created out of
nothing. Okay? In other words, we are a
failed science experiment.
Okay? That's why we suck.
>> That's why we must believe in the
church. All right? So, this is the
Augustine. All right. Um C can you read?
>> Yet man did not fall away to the extent
of losing all being. But when he had
turned towards himself, his being was
less real than when he adhered to him
who exist in a supreme degree. And so to
abandon God and to exist in oneself that
is to please oneself is not immediately
to lose all being but it is to come near
to nothingness. That is why the proud
are given another name in holy
scripture. They are called
self-pleasers. Now it is good to lift up
your heart and to exalt your thoughts
yet not in the self- worship of pride
but in the worship of God. This is a
sign of obedience and obedience can
belong only to the humble. So you must
obey the church completely. Okay?
Because divine spark in you, it's out of
nothingness. It can only lead you to
evil. Okay? So only way the only
solution now is to is to obey the church
completely.
>> And I think that kind of answered my
question too.
>> Yep.
>> So like for because I think I believe in
the original.
>> No, no, it doesn't matter what you
believe.
>> I don't care what you believe. I only
care about what the Catholic Church is
teaching you. Okay. Can can we also see
>> we're not having an argument about what
who's right, who's wrong. Yeah.
>> I don't want that. Okay.
>> I I want you to understand what the
Catholic Church is teaching you.
>> Like can we can we also see the like
people eat eat the fruit from that tree
also as a mistake that we can just like
the original Jesus believe that we can
be forgiven.
>> Jesus thought that what Eve did was
correct.
>> Oh.
>> All right. Okay.
All right. So Alan you read please
[snorts]
>> this is why humility
humility is highly priced in the city of
god and especially enjoyed on the city
of gods during the time of its
pilgrimage in this world and it receives
particular emphasis in the character of
Christ the king of the that city. We are
also taught by the sacred scriptures
that the thought of exaltation the
contrary of humility exercise supreme
dominion in Christ's adversary the devil
this is assuredly the greatest different
that thunders the two cities in which we
are speaking the one is a community of
devout men the other a company of the in
rel in religious and each has its own
angle angels
attached to it. In one city, love of God
has been given first place. In the
other, love of self.
>> Okay. So, it's it's that simple. Okay.
If you obey, you are doing the work of
God. If you disobey, you're doing the
work of the devil. It's that simple.
Okay. All right. Uh can you keep on
reading? And and and this this will end
the uh Yeah.
>> In the heavenly city, then there will be
freedom of well. It will be one and the
same freedom in all and invis individ
indivisible in the separate individuals.
It will be freed from all evil and
filled with all good enjoying
unfailingly the delight of internal
joys, forgetting all offenses,
forgetting all punishments.
>> So when when we have freedom, okay, we
we're slaves now, but when when we have
freedom, when we have when we're with
God, because only when we're with God,
can we know what is good, okay? And then
we have complete freedom. But what he
means by freedom of course is complete
obedience. Now we want even think about
disobeying God. Okay? That's what
freedom is.
All right?
So
uh the Catholic Church grows the the
Roman Empire makes it the official
religion because it does three things.
Okay? And we discussed this. The first
is that now you're better to exploit
your slaves. They're now more
hardworking because before
if they were lazy, they might get
whipped, right? But they're lazy now,
they will burn in hell for all for all
of eternity. That's number one. Number
two is this is really important.
You have all this gold, right? The
problem with all this gold is people can
can steal it. People can kill you for
it, right? But now you have spiritual
authority. Now you represent God. Now
you're head of a church, right? And
therefore people can't kill you because
if they kill you, God will come and kill
them. Okay, it's a pretty good deal,
right? Before you were a king, but now
you're a god. What a great deal. And the
last thing of course is now what you can
do is you can now expand and expand and
expand your empire. Okay.
Um,
so let me explain why this is relevant
today. Okay? Because now that the
Catholic Church is around, these
dynasties
of Rome can continue on to today through
the Catholic Church, right? Does that
make sense to you guys? Because now they
can store their power in the Catholic
Church. If you put your gold in the
Catholic Church, no one's going to come
and steal it, right? Because they don't
want to incur the wrath of God.
That's that's why
the Catholic Church will give rise to
something to to some to people called
the black nobility. Okay, these are 13
families from Rome that still run the
world today.
>> Okay, we'll discuss this later on.
>> All right, we'll discuss how the
Catholic Church and the black nobility
work together. Second something you need
to understand is what allowed the
Catholic Church to dominate is this
alliance between the black nobility and
Jews. Guess what guys? It still happens
today. Okay. The third thing is what
allows for the system to work are these
secret societies where through rituals
these powerful people are bound
together. Okay. And so these three ideas
the black nobility the alliance between
black nobility and the Jews and the
third are secret societies is the power
structure we have today. All right.
That's the power of the Catholic church.
That is the genius of Paul to create a
system that continues even today because
it is so powerful and um so strategic.
Okay, does that make sense? All right,
we'll discuss this later on as well, but
I present the idea to you today. All
right, some questions. Okay, um my wife
sends send sends me more questions.
Okay. Um, this person wants to know
what's the difference between the
Catholic Church, the Protestants, and
the Eastern Orthodox. Um, so the Eastern
Orthodox is the church of Augustine. It
doesn't it didn't really change. The
Protestants are those who rebel against
the teachings of Paul and Augustine. And
the Catholic Church is sort of in
between. Okay? But we'll discuss this
more um as we go along. All right.
Uh the Greek mystery schools, are they
still around today? And the answer is
yes. Of course, they're still around
today because they allow the elite to
work together. Okay? They they allow the
elite to trust each other. Okay? And
again, um they come from the Greek
mystery schools.
All right?
Psychopaths.
What do we do with these people? Right?
You have these psychopaths who run the
world. They can't they don't feel
regret. They don't forgive each other.
So how do we perceive these people?
Okay. And there are different solutions.
Um the first solution is to appreciate
the idea of karma. So yes, they are
powerful to like like in this lifetime
but maybe next lifetime they become
slaves. So they can feel for themselves
the evil that they've done onto other
people. Okay. Um, another idea is
in the world of today, psychopaths will
always war. Only evil will war because
that's just the structure of this
universe. In this universe that we live
in, the devil is always king. Okay? And
there's no way around it. So, we're here
not to um fight these people. We're here
to learn wisdom in a world of evil. So,
don't worry about them. Just worry about
yourself. Okay. The third thing to think
about is if you really understood how
these people live their lives, you would
feel sorry for them. All right? So
remember the Iliad where Achilles
triumphs over Hector, but rather than
feeling joy and happiness, he feels only
sadness and he can't even cry. Okay? He
he becomes a zombie. And you can make
the argument that the wealthy people are
like that today. Yeah, they look like as
though they're happy. They have billions
of dollars but they're not happy. Okay?
If you actually live their lives, if you
see the world through their eyes, you
would see that they're very unhappy
people. So don't hate them. Feel pity
for them. Okay. So there are different
ways of understanding this.
All right.
Okay. This is a great question. Okay. I
love this question. If the Romans are
the ones who killed Jesus,
why don't the Jews don't speak up? Why
don't the Jews say, "We didn't do it,
man." Okay, so this is really
complicated.
Uh, but the simple answer is
there's an agreement between the
Catholic Church and the Jews. Okay, the
agreement is this. The Catholic Church
needed scapegoats, needed people for
other people to hate. Okay? And the Jews
agreed in order to practice their
religion. Does that make sense? All
right? I know this sounds terrible, but
the only way for the Jews to survive as
a people is if they agree to be
scapegoats for Christians.
All right? And we'll discuss this later
on. And and that's why um if you look at
[clears throat] Europe for these 2,000
years, what the Christians did to the
Jews was just horrific. Okay? And the
Jews could not speak up because if they
did, the Catholic Church might get rid
of them. Okay?
Um, this person says, "James the just,
Jesus' brother, he was killed by the
Jews, right?" No, no, no. Ask yourself
this question. Who is most threatened by
James the Just? The answer, of course,
is Paul. It was Paul who had him killed.
Okay. In in 70, the Romans destroyed the
temple. And that time would would have
been the perfect time to kill James the
Just. James was probably protected by
the Jews. Okay? But Paul saw as a threat
because as long as James just was alive,
he's the ultimate authority on Jesus.
Right. Paul cannot steal the legacy from
uh James the Just. Therefore, he had to
had to had get this guy killed. Okay.
Does that make sense?
All right.
How do you know if you see the truth and
reject a lie? The answer is really
simple, guys. How do you know if you
love someone? You just do, guys. Okay.
I'm sorry. If you don't know you love
someone, you probably don't love that
person. All right. When you love
someone, your heart glows. You feel
stronger. You are more energetic.
All right? If you don't if you are in a
relationship, but you become weaker, you
feel tired, you lose hope, you probably
don't love that person. That that person
probably doesn't love you. Okay? It's
that simple, guys. If you How do you
know you're in love? You just do. How do
you know you see the truth? You just do.
All right. [snorts]
Um, you cannot trust a human. The Bible
clearly states the one who bring evil to
this world stands above all humankind.
Therefore, you will find truth. No, no,
no, no. This is what Paul says. This is
what Oxin said. Oxen says, "You do know.
You know in your heart." Okay.
All right. That's that's it. Any
questions, guys? Before we conclude.
Okay. Great. So, uh we'll continue this
next class. Okay.